the fashion world rocked by the news of
Kate Spade's passing everything we know
as the industry's biggest names gathered
for the CFDA Fashion Awards hey guys I'm
Denny direct oh this is the daily Denny
we've got actually a lot of fashion news
today including last night's
star-studded CFDA Fashion Awards and
Easter Race Kanye West shade but first
we've got some sad news to talk about
and I know it doesn't happen often here
but I'm afraid today is one of those
days
iconic fashion designer Kate Spade was
found dead in her Manhattan apartment of
an apparent suicide the New York Police
Department confirmed eet and Kate was
just 55 years old Spade was found by one
of her employees in her New York City
apartment and according to CBS New York
authorities say she left a note it goes
without saying but her designs have been
a staple on red carpet since she
launched the brand in the 90s which she
eventually sold in 2006 but it's her
infamous Kate Spade handbags that I
think is her real legacy and of course
many many are paying tribute to Kate
today the company she founded tweeted we
honor all the beauty she brought into
this world
Chelsea Clinton offered her condolences
sharing memories of her first Kate Spade
bag reese witherspoon mindy kaling and
so many more paid tribute and Kate's
passing is a good reminder for all of us
that depression does not discriminate
and mental health is important so if you
or someone you know needs help here's
the number for the National Suicide
Prevention lifeline take care of
yourselves guys
right the fashion world is indeed
mourning the loss of Kate Spade but last
night they gathered to celebrate it was
the annual CFDA Fashion Awards in New
York and that's where Kim Kardashian got
a big honor the first-ever influencer
award but she also got real with et's
Michelle Turner about how she really
felt about her man Kanye's controversial
remarks on slavery and about him airing
their dirty laundry in his new album yay
he's just the most genuine person
and you know he might say things that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind it but I
always know his heart on the album - he
said you know when he said those
comments you didn't let him off the hook
and you you know you guys had some
things to say I think a lot of us were
wondering like what is killing Reza did
she talk to him about it did she care
about that yeah we have those moments
and that was the one song that he didn't
really play for me until last minute so
I heard that last minute it meant a lot
to me we have different views sometimes
we have different things but that's my
husband you know I feel like you've
really kind of found your voice as a
woman which is great to see for all of
us who are all inspired me to really cuz
he's so confident and he would always
build up my confidence to be who I want
to be you know like I said I'll voice my
opinion when I think that there's
something that you know it's made me
done wrong or even if the messaging is
right maybe it the communication isn't
quite there to figure that out but I
always believe and trust in him that he
will always eventually explain himself
so I know what he really means when he
says something and I know that people
will - at some point I don't know about
you guys but I'm not sure I've seen Kim
this open and grounded and what she
believes and I can also appreciate how
rider died she is for her family
especially her husband but one person
who didn't let Kayne off the hook that
easily was the night's hosts Easter ray
where she made a very bold statement in
a royal blue pyre Moss jumpsuit she took
an even bigger fashion risk wearing a
belt with this message inscribed on it
every n-word is a star but the insecure
star didn't shy away from taking aim at
Kim Kardashian's hubby Kanye West during
her monologue
you know when I'm left to my own devices
I'm about as fashionable as Kanye is
black only when it's convenient
you guys that joke was my choice
just like slavery come on that punchline
comes after Kanye's controversial TMZ
live interview where he claimed slavery
was a choice and Issa might have thrown
shade at ya but she told et his wife
deserves her award we have that
interview and more on Kate Spade up at
et online.com all right guys that's it
for today we'll be back tomorrow with
another one until then like and comment
this video and thank you as always for
watching